nick chubs in your top is nick chupp in
your top three in your top five he's
definitely one of them
definitely no question baller supreme
we got the news yesterday injured
reserve with an mcl sprain now again
this year ir doesn't mean what it used
to mean once upon a time not that long
ago it meant when you're on ir you're
not coming back at all you can come back
after three weeks the rules of the
pandemic roster flexibility so you know
with an mcl sprain
there's no
who knows it depends on the degree
unless the ligament is completely torn
apart it heals itself unlike the acl so
with rest he can be back he'll be ready
to go there's been different reports
about how long he's going to miss six
weeks who knows but he's gonna miss at
least three and uh the good news is
hey they had 307 rushing yards and he
only had 43 of them chris so the the
rushing attack works and in a roundabout
way this may this may be in the browns
interest because to the extent that
they're fearing nick chubb showing up
after the season saying pay me yeah
you're right maybe a bill parcells
profanity from goodfellas on the front
end uh they can say we don't need to
yeah no i i it might play in their favor
to where yeah he can't sit there and go
well look i'm second in the nfl in
rushing yards again like he was last
year
uh you lose four or five games it's
gonna be hard for him to go back to the
table and go all right i want to be paid
like a a top-tier running back in
football and
hey for their credit everything about
him but we want to talk about dorsey the
prior gm but even this right here
the fact that they kept kareem hunt
around it's for right now and here we go
kareem hunt he's going to get a chance
to show that he's still the guy i know
he's been battling with some injuries as
well but between him and then the
earnest johnson
uh and how he ran the ball the other day
and if they can continue to kind of
infuse odell beckham jr and maybe jarvis
landry in creative ways they should be
okay running the ball i mean kareem hunt
is special i mean
when he before he got in trouble with
kansas city
everybody had him as a top five running
back in the game and he shows that he
still got that ability even last week he
did so i'm excited to watch him work
and durability's such an important
component regardless of what nick chubb
does when he comes back
the best running backs are the ones that
are on the field all the time and i know
injuries at a certain point are
inevitable but emmitt smith ended up
with the all-time rushing record not
because he was the fastest or the most
agile the most elusive he was able to go
and go and go and go and that there's
value in that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports